see it vampires
ooh scary fictions if you go back
and look at all the movies that included
vampires from the past few years
you would notice that there are vampire
movies and then there are movies that
just flat out make fun of vampires
vampires don't do dishes
this got me wondering why are we so
obsessed with these mythical creatures
i don't know about you but i'm gonna
need some background before uncovering
this mystery
[Music]
the general myth of vampires has existed
for
centuries and were almost as popular as
they are today
back in the middle ages the universally
accepted characteristics of vampires
are that they consume human blood i hit
the main artery
they go out at night and avoid sunlight
they have superhuman strength
hello vampire a hypnotic effect on their
victims
and can't see themselves in mirrors
pretty
run-of-the-mill stuff that pretty much
anyone would know
the history of vampires in film
pre-dating twilight
is all a bit boring compared to the
saucy and addicting drama this series
added to the vampire trope
vampires have always been considered to
be prominent figures in film and media
specifically from the inception of this
guy nosferatu
even if you don't know him by name it's
likely that this figure is surprisingly
familiar
that's because he's undeniably famous
showing up
plenty of time since his original debut
in 1922
even showing up in an episode of
spongebob
following nosferatu came dracula in 1931
and then again in the 90s and you you
pretty much know how it goes from here
creepy castles some cape wearing and a
lot of i want to drink your blood blah
blah blah
i don't say blah blah blah
there are literally dozens of reasons
why vampires are such attractive
characters to human audiences
psychologically people tend to be drawn
to partners that have enough resources
to grant them
and their children good survival rates
this doesn't just refer to racks on
racks of cash
vampires are immortal i became a vampire
when i was 16
and living forever is perhaps the most
amazing resource of all when you're
looking out for your child's future
people also desire partners who have the
ability to protect their children
and themselves which vampires obviously
have down pat
considering their ridiculous superhuman
strength and durability
lastly basichumanpsychology.com
themselves
write that vampires are just hot
she for real they know how to play into
that human flirtation
and can easily romance those that they
meet allowing them to play into people's
romantic preferences
there is a lot more to our obsession
with vampires
we are drawn to these figures because
they're loners
who never truly feel alone something
human beings might envy
or desire to embody themselves that way
we don't need to fear rejection and
could either live our lives happily with
those who do accept us
or alone in peace vampires themselves
can also avoid the annoyingness of
technological change
they don't rely on technology for their
needs and have survived throughout time
despite the technology that's available
to them it's quite
amazing to see how far technology can
go forward this independence is
something that humans would surely
benefit from
since we would never run out of anything
that would leave us in danger
except for blood of course they are
powerful
both in the sense of their physical
abilities but also in their intelligence
having the ability to live forever gives
one the opportunity to study and perfect
whatever their heart desires this
capacity to be inhumanly smart
is alluring not only because of the
benefits it would bring you
but also because it's something that we
simply can't have
making it more desirable their
supernatural abilities
are not the only thing that we're
jealous of let's
talk about their looks you find this
beautiful
magical when you're a vampire you become
very
there's no denying that vampires are
totally cool looking
if not totally attractive as well they
have pale skin
fangs and amazing bone structure i mean
what's not to envy
their need for very little sleep while
maintaining immaculate looks
is something that any human being would
surely desire for themselves
by definition vampires are the ultimate
bad boys
they live however they want regardless
of the law they don't care
about other people they are free
vampires are all that we
as humans want but can't have making
them clearly desirable subjects that we
can't help but give our attention to
despite the pretty plentiful amount of
vampire references and media pre-dating
the 2000s
including buffy the vampire slayer
interview with a vampire
and underworld vampires seem to get
their steam back as a trend with the
inception of the twilight
series no longer are vampires just
creepy guys living in remote castles who
want to prey on young women
they're now attractive young men and
women who have the potential to romance
any human they want
talk about an upgrade the vampires in
the twilight series
they take on all the classic
characteristics that vampires usually
embody
except almost always with a twist like
they don't burn in the sunlight they
glow and they crave human blood but
are vegetarian they embody all the
characteristics of vampires which
naturally draws humans to vampires they
have the ability to run away from the
annoyingness of everyday life
and survive wherever they please they
have mastered their crafts
passions and intelligence standing out
is probably the smartest students at
their local high school
and as the best in their field as
carlisle is i don't know which side of
the camp you were on but
you know people either loved this series
or despised it those who loved the
series
really really loved it most of the
fanatic audience of this series
was made up of young women who grew
attached to the fantastical creatures of
the plot
and the love triangle in which they were
involved most likely
some of you watching probably went
through a twilight phase at some point
arguing with your besties about whether
jacob or edward deserved to be bella's
love
i certainly know i was in that position
when i was 13.
a whole bunch of new television dramas
popped up after the series gained big
amounts of attention
vampire diaries also had a big run of
fame and popularity
it was on the air for eight years
starting in 2011
with 171 episodes similarly to twilight
a love triangle takes center stage in
this vampire series as well
focusing on a human teenage girl stuck
between two brothers who are both in
love with her
talk about being stuck between a vampire
and a hard place vampire diaries was so
popular in fact
that the producers decided to make it
immortal just like the vampires that
star in it
okay not really but the originals was
spawned as its spin-off of the show in
2013
lasting a year longer than vampire
diaries and bringing fans whole new
levels of drama
and then ever more recently legacies was
created as another spin-off of the show
it seems like these television vampires
might
actually live forever true blood was yet
another series about vampires that came
about because of twilight's impact
in a lot of ways true blood set itself
apart from vampire diaries and twilight
it included lgbtq stories and narratives
it brought a little more horror to the
vampire name and had lots of messaging
about civil rights in its narrative
it's also quite different from these
other series as
vampires live peacefully within human
society these shows
all include vampires with very similar
traits as those in twilight
making them just as appealing to their
viewers all of these vampires
immortality
and unlimited resources intrigued many
viewers
enough for all of these shows to be on
the air for more than 6 years each
not as long as a vampire's lifetime
but impressively long if you ask me as
much as those super fans may
really really love twilight vampire
diaries and true blood
there was also another side to the
public who absolutely
hated the twilight series this movement
of resentment
clearly had to result in a film movement
of its own
the vampire parody movie this included
such titles as
vampires suck suck vamps
and breaking wind among many more
very original titles vampires suck and
breaking wind are two films that
directly make fun of the twilight series
the rest of the films are not direct
reactions to twilight but take on the
very same vampire tropes with
really tacky portrayals and simple humor
very much making fun of the concept of a
vampire and poking fun at those who like
them
so with all of this reasoning as to why
vampires are
actually admirable creatures for humans
why is there so much hate around vampire
obsessions
there is no actual reason that people
should have had such a complete
adverse reaction to the twilight series
vampire diaries or
any other vampire series all of these
series are
more or less just run-of-the-mill
franchises that
play into people's penchants for romance
and drama there's no denying that
something about vampires is inherently
cool
nothing about people's obsessions with
vampires is out of the ordinary
as we've seen it actually makes a ton of
sense
we have always since the very beginning
of film and television
been obsessed with the idea and image of
the
all-powerful vampire our psychology
literally drives us to love these
fantastical creatures
despite their potential for horror and
destruction but
of course that dangerous quality only
makes us want them more
so which vampire series caught your
attention the most
whose team were you on let us know in
the comments below thanks for watching
give this video a big thumbs up and
subscribe to the things for more great
content about your favorite tv shows and
movies
we'll see you next time